babies this young are extremely
responsive to the emotions and the
reactivity and the social interaction
that they get from the world around them
this is something that we started
studying oh 30 40 years ago when people
didn't think that infants could engage
in social interaction
in this still face experiment what the
mother did was she sits down and she's
playing with her baby who's about a year
of age
and she gives a greeting to the baby the
baby gives a greeting back to her yeah
this baby starts pointing at different
places in the world and the mother is
trying to engage her and play with her
they're working to coordinate their
emotions and their intentions what they
want to do in the world and that's
really what the baby is used to and then
we ask the mother
to not respond to the baby
the baby very quickly picks up on this
and then she uses all of her abilities
to try and get the mother back
she smiles at the mother
she points because she's used to the
mother looking where she points
the baby puts both hands up in front of
her and says What's Happening Here
she makes that
screechy sound at the mother like come
on why aren't we doing this
even in this two minutes when [__]
[__] why are you not talking to me
the baby looks at you and you look back
at it and then you look at the baby like
a [__] to me he's like yeah
Let's Play that video I can't believe
this happened
what do you think about California
I like it yeah do you like it
you taking a [__]
that will never know you funny
that's really what California is now
[__] you like things yeah you like it
yeah you
taking this [__]
okay when I was living over there and my
parents like you like it over there I'm
like yeah like you like it like [__]
they don't get the normal reaction they
react with negative emotions they turn
away they feel the stress of it they
actually may lose you can see it's a
very difficult to the mom to have to sit
there still facing other kids suffering
even though she's like this you can see
the Rings yeah this is hard for her yeah
and the kids suffer
[Music]
and what are you doing
oh yes oh what a big girl this video is
brought to you by surf shark no matter
where I'm at all right whether it's uh
in my house or in my Airbnb one on my
way or in Antarctica
or or even when I'm taking a [__] I need
to have access to all my programs hey
but sometimes the internet doesn't allow
me for that because it's restricted
because of the area that I'm in
yeah and for that I need a system that
allows me to change my location
and that's called a VPN changer yes in a
wonderful VPN that I'm using is surf
shark and allows you to just change the
location of where you are and you can
watch everything that you want no matter
where you're at right now with Surfside
you can just use promo code Abba and
preach and you're gonna be able to have
83 off plus there's a plus
three months extra free
I know crazy get on it
it's a little like The Good the Bad and
the Ugly the good
is that normal stuff that goes on that
we all do with our kids
the bad is when
something bad happens but the infant can
overcome it after all when you stop the
still face the mother and the baby start
to play again
the ugly is when you don't give the
child any chance to get back to the good
there's no reparation and they're stuck
in that really
ugly situation what do you think yeah
and personally we're joking everything
and stuff but
um
uh it it just reminds me what I was
working for uh
for child support that child
protective uh Department you know some
of the parents that you know to still
face mom
some of the parents that when they are
in their down of drugs they look exactly
like that there's just no reaction
because they're like because they're
high or because they're starting to come
down okay yeah so they're just like this
and they're raising young kids right and
you can see later the effect of that
well you can see yes and no uh maybe I'm
biased and stuff like that there was
other things you know with the kid and
everything but yeah there is a
difference with the interactions with
stuff like that and it can it can
um affect from what I've seen again like
I don't have a lab coat but it's from
what I've experienced right you could
either you could either see people that
are very
uh
uh clothes on themselves because they
don't know how to interact or people
because of that
can can like they want to go out there
and get the attention and in the wrong
way
right in the wrong way they try to seek
that attention so
if you give the same situation to a
human being and a human being and
development you're gonna have different
results but definitely it is going to
affect that person that's just what it
reminds me of those times dealing with
people when I was going to see my my
friends
as well in the projects and you could
see some families that they were not
there and you could see the effects on
the effect on the kid
so that's what it reminds me of yeah I
made me think about like cell phone and
mask usage
looks like oh [__] yeah a lot of people
be raising their kids but they're not
even really there because I understand
like
it's a lot of Maintenance to be around a
child all the time some people take it
above and beyond where they're like
really away from the child for long
periods of time but sometimes you're
around the kid for a long period of time
and use on your phone you just barely
like looking at them
um
and
I wonder what kind of effect that has
wow because it's not just about like you
know they do studies on
um how much time a parent spends with
their kid and what the better outcomes
are for the child itself but it's also
like the quality of the time you spend
together
you know some people it's like it's like
you know when couples complain they're
like oh my husband's here but he's
always on his phone or he's always doing
work or he's not really there it's like
people want you to be present they want
you to feel like while you're around
them you're really there I imagine even
for children the same way when the woman
had a still face when you guys still
face looking at another device and the
kid's trying to interact with you I
imagine that's got to also be really
negatively harmful yeah
there's definitely that you see how it
affected the kid not probably not in the
long term
right there on that video the time we
pass in the pandemic with the mass on
you know there's a bunch of kids
that definitely it affected for sure for
sure for sure for sure
you know yeah I could definitely see
that happening like this the generation
that we have kids right now they lived
through that it was it was a traumatic
event yeah it's not about saying like
whether maths are good or not it's not
funny it's it's just understanding what
are the other ramifications of use of
those kinds of functions for kids who
really rely on Facebook like to
understand the world around them it
really impacts their ability to
understand what the other person's
feeling or interacting with
um and then even for adults like I think
through the pandemic masks rated people
who are uglier much more attractive and
people who were attract more attractive
much uglier and so it [__] our
perception up of people in the way they
look but it also made it much more
difficult to read social cues and to
interact it made us more distant in many
ways not so much that they were uglier
but their beauty power did not work
anymore you know when you use so much of
having this and then you present
yourself and people like now you just
have this we don't know it's not so much
that they were uglers that that [__]
don't work because I can't see it I
can't none of that so yeah I I I I I I
can see that it can have an effect on
people and then like it can definitely
change people yeah interactions were all
different how close we were with people
and now we're a little bit more distance
and
there was a sense of fear at some point
like
you got it you know what I mean so so
yeah definitely again like you said it's
not saying that
was not a reason for doing that or no
reason it's just you have to understand
all the things that come into play it's
not just oh yeah we're doing this for
that cool but what else is it what else
is this affecting yeah kids are very
perceptive like being around like they
can see when your face changes they stop
and they look at you it's like oh I know
that face they're upset and they start
crying because like if he's upset now
I'm upset right I've seen it I see I've
seen it firsthand I see like a parent
just look at a kid and the kid just
loses it right at the same time if you
get very playful with a kid like you but
the kid starts playing as well and so
they're obviously reading their mood off
of you and depending on how you treat
them over long periods of time it's
going to severely impact their mental
well-being I see what happens to a child
when they're in a good space for a long
periods of time and their mood improves
over time and I see what happens when
they're in a dark place and you see how
it like makes it hard for them to open
up over a long period so whether they're
infants whether they're little children
the way you behave around them the kind
of faces that you might make the way
that you that we say energy but energy
is probably just the amalgamation of
like all the little things that you're
doing with your face your body posture
your habits that is being like put into
one thing and the energy you exude will
also impact those around you so you know
when you see here in this experiment
with children but even with adults you
know like you got a partner you want to
communicate with them but something like
they're just not communicating well you
feel like they're not but you look at
their body posture the way that they
look at you and you can feel contempt or
whatever that'll [__] with your mind
it's not just a kid thing like you you
ever date somebody you're like yo what's
changed wait look at me it feels a bit
different I don't [__] with your brain
um and so what's the point of all this
it's just to be aware of how we carry
ourselves to be aware of like what all
this does and what it does to other
people around us
um
yeah just to be aware especially the
phone thing the phone thing I think is
like much more harmful than people take
on especially when you're with a group
of people and you're constantly on it
and you're really absent like that has
an effect on them even though they may
not or outwardly complain or go home and
cry about it it has a negative effect on
the people around you you know
um so yeah that's pretty much all let us
know what you guys think